so so i'll bring up my my twitter or my
facebook
uh thing today i i woke up today and
i i had that interaction um for those
who weren't here earlier
it was just about covid numbers weird
right
someone banned me from their thing and i
was like you know what i'm sick of this
i'm sick of seeing these meme
news where people are reading their news
from memes that were
which it's not true none of this is true
i just posted i'm voting for trump
if you have a problem with it you know
love it or hate it
talk to me i'd love to talk to you about
it let's let's you know let's get this
out into the open
and man it is it is on fire there was a
lot of respectful dissent
absolutely and there were some some
people like
i can't remember what one was but they
were like later bye yeah
gone i knew you were a kook yeah yeah
yeah and
and everyone's like i can't believe you
can can
you know vote for uh a bigot and a
racist
and this person that you know it was
is there a specific region for these for
some of these people
it is interesting that you you should
say that because yes
a lot of them are on the west coast a
lot of them are along the west coast and
the democratic zones
there's some people in new york also
which is a very
democratic area you know it's like
i was i was talking to a friend of mine
today we were having a conversation
about black lives matter and stuff and
they asked me are you going to vote for
trump and i said
here are several reasons why i'm leaning
towards yes okay why i'm leaning towards
yes and the republicans
and i talked like a little bit about
section 230 i talked about
identitarianism
i talked about how basically having no
real good choices but what am i going to
pick
biden the dudes look at trump can at
least fly a plane he's flying it crazy
he's doing like barrel rolls and people
are screaming
yeah but joe biden man he's smart he
knows exactly what he's doing
what i mean by what trump is doing is
that like he's flying in a way that many
people
whether it's because of the flight
attendants screaming in their faces
non-stop yeah
people are upset but he's flying a plane
you know joe biden would fall asleep
and then the plane would just go um well
basically the response from my friend
out of chicago was
interesting like oh yeah i don't know i
think i'm going to vote for biden blah
blah blah
like i didn't no nobody screamed in my
face that's nice you know
but but i think it has to do with like
the west coast
is insane it's full of insane people
there's a lot of people in new york too
that
a lot of people from were posting from
new york as well but
you know one thing that i started
noticing was
there was a lot of people that did post
that were like awesome adam
and one one friend of mine in particular
um
was from venezuela oh yeah and he said
he said i'm i'm absolutely for trump
i'm from venezuela i know what happens
i've been there i've been through it
and i don't want this to happen here i'm
there
i'm voted for trump dude no doubt they
thought it couldn't happen
but what pisses me off is a lot of them
were saying how can you vote for this
racist
how can you vote for this this bigot
this you know homophobe and it's like
all i can think of is like how how can
you guys just hate so much
when like the more i learn about him you
know what he's done for the minute
minority communities
that they don't want to talk about well
so
have you asked them what has he done
that's racist
you know they always say what well first
he called mexicans rapists right and
then my response is like
he was talking specifically about
illegal immigration
and like alluding to the high rate of
crime
you know ms-13 things like that right he
called immigrants animals
no he was referring to cartels well he
banned muslims well first the list of
these countries that were
considered threats was from the obama
administration and he also included
north korea and venezuela
which are not muslim plus there's
several other muslim nations that
weren't banned so
but he called it a muslim ban that he
did
so you got it you got to eat look i i
always say like listen man does he have
the tact
exactly maybe not character but is he
doing
doing good things as a president yes
definitely got to give it to a man the
economy absolutely the economy did
really well
mm-hmm uh i can't blame him for covid he
did not get us into another war and he's
been trying to pull our soldiers out and
i gotta admit
economics is always good you know if
people in the in this country are doing
well
and around the world i'm happy but my
main thing has always been
i'm tired of having arguments about
health care
and flint and all these things when
we're literally spending money
on the war machine so that we can be
nation-building in the middle east
right why are we doing that we want to
look john bolton's wanted to go after
iran it's like
i love that onion article i mentioned it
before it's john bolton breaks into oval
office screaming that he's been shot by
iran and he's
it's a picture of him like holding his
chest with blood coming up yes we get it
john bolton said something like next
year we will be celebrating in tehran or
something like that
and then we've got bases in iraq we've
got based in afghanistan and there's
iran right in the middle yeah we get it
we get it
imperialist whatever you want to call it
i i i love the people of this country
who are willing to
uh you know put themselves on the line
to defend our ideals and our freedoms
but i'm upset that the machine is
putting them in a country for nation
building
we don't need to be doing that and trust
me i know a lot about the the natural
gas pipelines the gas from monopoly
russia ukraine crimea all of these
things i get it
i fall i fall on the other side of this
argument because i just if
i think it's it's a very weird position
because it's the progressive but also
america first
yeah it was the conversation between
tulsi gabbard and dan crenshaw should we
have troops in the middle east dan says
look we really need it there's a power
vacuum
china and russia they can move in
tulsa's saying we got to bring our
troops back and i'm like bringing our
troops home
defending ourselves rebuilding our roads
rebuilding our plumbing
in investing in minority communities and
impoverished communities
to better their lives yes this is all
what we can do for our community
and one of the things we can do is we
don't need to be investing in
the war machine now granted a lot of
that money is spent here a lot of people
don't know this
like when they build a tank and stuff
like that there's people who work
american jobs in this country
but then we're building roads you know
we're we're building we're putting up
buildings we're building cities in these
other countries and it's like you know
what man look
i would love the idea of a utopian
global
community star trek future maybe in the
future maybe we can work towards this
but i don't believe the way is to invade
a country invade two countries
start you know building our own building
other countries there i'm just
um you've got to give me a better reason
and if they can for security reasons
then you got a problem because this is a
this is a country uh
that that requires the consent of the
governed if you do not get my consent
for what you're doing because you can't
justify it you've got
yourself a problem there i would like to
see the money invested
in our troops i would like to see invest
in such a way that our troops can be
defending protecting and helping
americans who are in crisis
and we've got a problem going on in the
detroit area and the flint area with
water
that for some reason they're not fixing
you know
there's a lot of things that can be done
to fix that the reason i don't talk
about it the reason i don't make videos
where i'm like what about flint i'm like
because
war and that's why when i see trump is
like i would like to get our troops out
of syria i'm like
okay hey i'm mad that he fired those
missiles at syria when they're like what
about
you know trump wants to get our troops
out of out of afghanistan i'm like here
here good sir i raise a glass please and
then and then the republicans and
democrats are like
hold up yeah hold up i'm like no no no
no no don't hold up
yeah why why you know what man there
there is a real concern about power
vacuums and stuff like that
but listen the biggest threat i think we
face is china
i agree i agree not russian russia
coming into afghanistan or whatever this
is
why why why do you think that though
china yeah yeah give me your give me
your reasons
infiltration of our cultural
institutions over academic institutions
manipulation of the of the public
perception and psyche
the uh i believe that
you know when you look at things like
tick and spying
yes they've been engaging in espionage
and subversive tactics they've been
stealing our manufacturing base they've
been stealing our intellectual property
they've been extracting our resources
so they can enrich themselves and that
is hurting us
and when we had these complicit
politicians you know what's more
dangerous
than a power vacuum in the middle east
china stealing our ip
and then american politicians giving our
manufacturing away to
china yup so that the american middle
class suffers and then you end up with a
decimated
michigan which results in the collapse
of the water infrastructure in places
like flint
so how about we come home and help our
people
help marginalize communities i'll tell
you what if the left came to me and said
we want a big push to you know allocate
funds to saving the
the oppressed minorities of the flint
area i would say 100
here's my offer how about we take the
funds from the from the middle eastern
incursions
bring those soldiers home reunite them
with their families give a big old bonus
even
because we're gonna save a ton of money
and then with whatever money we have
we have whatever we can with the
military the national guard going and
start fixing these things to
help our own people boom bring our jobs
back bring our manufacturing back
the bigger threat is the loss of our of
our economic standing
if we don't have jobs for the middle
class if they can afford to eat if they
can't
afford to buy homes if china is buying
up uh property on the west coast
buying up all these houses and taking
our factories away they are and our
medicine
general manufacturing then what's going
to be left of this country in 20 years
yet the obsession is we got to have
soldiers in afghanistan
it's just absolutely psychotic it's
stretching us too thin it's a waste of
time so this ultimate it comes down to
tim why don't you talk about these that
or this was like okay yeah yeah yeah get
them out of afghanistan
i'll tell you what right now we i wrote
a song
remember the song i wrote the other day
in the room yeah it was great i wrote a
punk rock song
it was called end the war f the imperial
fascists vote donald trump
yep i'm like i don't know tell you man
this is what punk is nowadays
if you want to end the war in the middle
east who do you vote for joe biden
no right donald trump is literally
trying to bring our soldiers back
yep so i'm like this is the weirdest the
weirdest song you'd ever write he's
he's literally trying to make our
citizens
stronger smarter people yeah vote
republican to end the war seriously what
yeah yeah did you look at the did you
look at the panel that biden is starting
to kind of pull together
it would be the third term of obama's
presidency
yeah great dropping bombs on pakistanis
obama was just a man what a role model
he was not
he was not good he was not good he you
know i feel like domestically he was
just
you know enough average you know what's
really charismatic
in this movie um uncle tom that we were
discussing earlier
it it has a speech by him and it's a
great speech
it's i i still feel like it holds true
today
and he talks about america being an
incredible place and that if anyone
thinks that
like um i i don't exactly i don't
remember his exact words but he's
basically saying if anyone thinks that
you can't do anything
if you feel like you're so oppressed in
this amazing country that is america
look at me right now i am the president
and i was like oh good sir good sir
and like he proved it anyone
we you know you you can be president
anyone can doesn't matter what your skin
is it matters what your character is
that's america
and that's what we need that's what we
cherish here character
dude they're erasing martin luther king
jr's dream i have a dream that one day
my children will be judged not by the
color of this game with the content of
their character he said
i have a dream and it is deeply rooted
in the american dream that's what he
said
verbatim that's what he said and then
and then the rest
but it is the american dream that he was
talking about
and that that is not what they're doing
right now i wonder we're trying to break
that down
that my great grandparents thought they
had to come to this country
that they had to flee where they were
even though this is supposedly
a historically racist country this place
is so bad people are
are dying to get here yep dying
but it's worth it because they know that
they can be free here
and they can do what they want to do and
we're basically you know one of the
the least racist countries on the planet
if not the probably when i went to
sweden i learned something really
interesting
i learned that they're very culturally
homogeneous
true i don't want to say racist
necessarily because they don't like
other white people either
i didn't we did an interview with a
woman who was from america who married a
swedish man
okay she spoke swedish but she had an
accent she couldn't get hired anywhere
because once they you know they would
look at her resume and everything bring
her in
and then she said as soon as she would
talk to them their faces would would
change
oh where are you from america oh that's
interesting no call back
yeah they were very like well
i mean i've been i've been living in in
europe on and off for
15 years so i am
constantly meeting people that go oh
you're american i know everything about
you
yeah done you what because i'm american
you realize america's huge right
like you're gonna i counter with this
this is my favorite thing for
uh i'm in paris for this example right
someone says it to me
oh so you're you're just like uh that
german you're just like the germans then
whoa whoa whoa excuse me
no no no i am i'm french and i'm like
what's the difference you live
closer to germany than me living
in texas from chicago to texas to
california like you you don't you don't
understand what you what that means then
that all americans are the same or all
television
or all the news that makes it over here
you go to chicago
you talk about the bears you
you know what i'm saying and uh you go
to brooklyn and
and both of these guys are going to be
telling you about their hot dogs and
their pizza
like did we even talk different i mean
it's mostly going away because the
internet true but you go down to texas
you see cowboy hats and guns and
barbecue yeah good barbecue you can't
get the barbecue anywhere else
you can't get gardener anywhere dude
this is good chardonnay good jar now
yeah i've tried it you can't find it you
can find it
only in chicago they call it hot peppers
yeah it's not this nah get out
you're talking about you got to get the
right sized cauliflower bits and
people people are probably like what's
your ordinary i have no idea well for
the people who
don't know what jardiner is it's a
chicago thing you wouldn't understand
sorry but but but yeah but well here's
the point i was making with sweden
sweden is supposedly this very
progressive you know
leftward country right and even they
have prejudices they're a small
tight-knit country it's what you say
nine million people well they they have
a
i'm going to use the term far right um
and part of their country part of their
government it's relative people
but people also say well look at look at
socialism look at sweden like how isn't
it you know look at that
and it's like okay yeah it's a country
of nine million but they're not even
socialist
and they're right it's a capitalist
market economy right it's a specific
it they've found their their spot
and we can't just shift you know it's
like this is what they do that's what
they say
scandinavia is socialist or democratic
socialist when they're not
they're market economies with welfare
states and in the instance of sweden
they're subsidized by weapons exports
that's true so it's like i'll tell you
what if you're one of the largest
weapons exporters per capita
your state is making a ton of money you
can probably afford to give a little bit
to all the people
nine million of them in your country
there's a reason they didn't enter world
war ii
they were they were the the weapons
that's they were that's yeah and you
know what would be socialist
if the the factories were owned by the
state
or at least partially or even to any
degree they're not i don't know i don't
know that much about it
socialism is public ownership of the
means of production okay so bernie
sanders proposed like 20
percent of all company stock goes to the
workers or something like that for like
paying out bonuses and stuff
that's socialism right you go my
understanding at least of like denmark
and
sweden norway they don't do that you own
a business you pay taxes
that's interesting because uh i have a
friend who used to work at tesla
um before elon made some moves because
he was taking heat from
something or other that he always does
making moves
um i guess he was putting too much time
into spacex
and the tesla board was upset
that he was losing tesla money so he
kind of had
he had to reformat but what i'm what i'm
uh
talking about is a lot of the people
that work at tesla got stocks
in the company including my friend so
even when he he
uh lost his job at the company he still
had a lot of stocks i still think he
does which is
pretty sweet you know for him so they
got these stock options
when working there yeah so it was
actually a part of his company that's
kind of cool i mean we
we do this we we offer options we offer
stock appreciation rights things like
that yeah yeah
so but you know if we actually said that
the state owns a portion of each company
we'd be getting into socialism right we
don't do that so we we
we're mostly a mixed economy through
taxes and stuff but
anyway my ultimate point was america is
not racist
like when when you for the most part
it's not america is not racist you're
absolutely right i agree listen
it's not when you go to start a business
or open a bank account they don't say
i'm sorry because of your race yeah a
lot of countries do
maybe maybe specific welfare um
systems are racist because they were set
into place
45 years ago well when they were
mixing it you know and there's a lot of
that conversation about institutional
racism
i mean and it's the last sure like
trying to make that happen you're
absolutely right i mean even like
planned parenthood you know i learned a
lot about it we've
lydia has has you know said some things
that got me thinking
so i did some digging and then sure
enough uncle tom
boom they dropped a whole bunch of stuff
about that specific thing
about margaret sanger and how nasty she
was an activist a nasty woman
yeah there's an activist website that's
uh plots on a map
planned parenthood locations and it
points out that
79 percent are within walking distance
of the black and latino communities
it's messed up so kanye was saying
almost almost 1400
kids a day from just black mothers
but you th this this this conversation
about planned parenthood is
very nuanced because it is like and most
honestly most things are but right
when you know when you talk to when i
talk to my most almost all my friends
are left
you know when i talk to them they don't
like they see these things and to them
they're like i don't i don't i don't see
it that way because like for instance my
body my right
when i talk to my left wing female
friends they say i
needed i i have no job i have almost no
money because kovid and i was able to go
there for free health care
they didn't go there for abortions like
that and they were like if it wasn't for
them i'd be in serious trouble well and
that's that's when i when we first kind
of talked about it i was like you know
they do more things than just this it's
not
you know it's it's it's more like i i
got tested
you know because everyone should get
tested you know for whatever you
you know any stds or whatever it's like
you know i did that and
here's the important points it was great
listen
if there are people who need service and
they can't afford it and planned
parenthood provides that
excellent i'm happy they do yeah if
black activists are saying they feel
threatened
because they think these institutions
are targeting them then i think we need
to listen to what they have to say
especially if you believe in black if
you believe in black lives matter
yeah if these people come to you and say
please listen your your response should
be i'm listening
that's what they say right they say you
should be listening with these actors
have to say so i respect it yeah i do
but but also the same thing is true for
my female you know left-leaning friends
when they're like i was in desperate
need and they helped me
i respect that too let's have a
conversation and figure out what we need
to do as a country to come together
i understand everyone's got grievances
we we we have to we have to we have we
have to learn how to function properly
as you know two wings of the same eagle
you know otherwise we thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the
full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode